I don't think I've been in as invested
in anything this much since Deadpool
I am very turned on right now for me
it's a it's one of those things where
all the eggs are in the basket I'm super
excited to unleash this on the world so
this New York comic-con crowd is
literally an exclusive and first time
anyone ever anywhere is going to see
anything so that spoke daunting and
super exciting yeah it's the entire cast
was out in support of Canadian director
Shawn Levy Snoop project-free guy Ryan
Reynolds was taking selfies with fans
backstage killing eaves Jodie comer was
hugging stranger things star Joe Keary
and Tycho ytt was pretending he'd never
worked with Ryan before and now to
finally have a chance to work together
for the first time ever and both of our
lives super stoked about their be in the
same room Green Lantern yeah yeah Green
Lantern Seth Rogen Green Hornet it's
this that's where you'll get in
confusion amazing in that but neither of
us the states were okay
no you did Green Lantern there's
definitely Green Line right yeah there's
a lot of fun in action there's a lot of
you know great comedy and great
performances done or dick you lessness
then and then and then yeah I think yeah
at the heart of the whole thing there's
kind of a nice message that I guess you
can't kind of I can't really get into
yeah I think people will enjoy for
multiple reasons and the movies about a
bank teller who wakes up and finds out
that he's a background player in a video
game like in a crazy violent insane
video game and I think that that's also
something that people look around these
days and they think you know watching
the news or they're just wandering
outside of their house they just
sometimes it feels a little bit like
that you got yeah you pinch yourself is
yeah this can't be actually real like
evenings you feel like you're just kind
of a passenger on this ride that you
have no control over and if you feel
overwhelming you can we can all feel
powerless right like in life in this
world in these times